Am Dienstag, den 26. April 2022, fand auf
der US Air Base im pfälzischen Ramstein einer
der bedeutendsten internationaler Gipfel der
letzten Jahre statt:
Mehr als 40 verbündete Länder kamen zusammen,
um der Ukraine jene notwendige militärische
Unterstützung zuzusichern, mit der sie den
Ansturm der russischen Invasionstruppen zurückschlagen
kann.
Allein in den ersten zwei Monaten seit Beginn
der Invasion haben die Verbündeten mehr als
5 Milliarden Dollar an Militärhilfe an die
Ukraine geliefert.
("Niemand lässt sich von Putins fadenscheinigen
Gründen oder seinen falschen Behauptungen
über den Donbass täuschen [...] Russlands
Invasion ist nicht zu rechtfertigen.
Genauso wie die russischen Gräueltaten [...] Nationen
guten Willens aus der ganzen Welt sind sich
einig in ihrer Entschlossenheit, die Ukraine
in ihrem Kampf gegen die imperiale Aggression
Russlands zu unterstützen."
Lloyd Austin, US-Verteidigungsminister)
Liebe VisualPolitik-Zuschaer, die russische
Invasion hat nicht nur Solidarität mit der
Ukraine ausgelöst, sondern auch eines deutlich
gemacht: Tyrannen kann man nicht trauen.
Schon gar nicht aus so feindlich gesinnten
Ländern wie Russland.
Man muss sich eben auf den Krieg bzw. die
Verteidigung gegen diesen vorbereiten, wenn
man es mit dem Frieden wirklich ernst meint.
Ein Grundprinzip, das nun praktisch jeder
klar denkende Mensch in allen verbündeten
Ländern begriffen hat.
Von Deutschland über Japan bis Australien.
(Deutsche Verteidigungsinvestitionen werden
die Neuverschuldung im Jahr 2022 verdoppeln)
(Wie der Ukraine-Krieg Japan verändert.
Tokio bewegt sich auf eine selbstbewusstere
Sicherheitsstrategie zu)
Aber gerade in den Ländern des ehemaligen
Warschauer Paktes trifft diese Erkenntniss
auf den fruchtbarsten Boden.
(Wenn wir das Schlimmste, nämlich Krieg,
vermeiden wollen, müssen wir nach der alten
Regel handeln, die besagt: 'Wenn du Frieden
willst, bereite dich auf den Krieg vor'" - Jarosław
Kaczyński, stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
Polens und Vorsitzender der PiS)
Praktisch alle mittel- und osteuropäischen
Länder haben erkannt, dass sie sich auf einen
Krieg vorbereiten müssen.
Das sie setzten genau das nun konsequent und
blitzschnell um.
Allen voran schreitet jedoch ein Land, das
sich allmählich zu einer einflussreichen,
ja führenden europäischen Macht entwickelt,
gegen welche die alten Taktgeber der EU immer
blasser dastehen.
Und dieses aufstrebende Land, was es mit ihm
auf sich hat und wohin es Europa führen wird,
sehen wir uns heute ganz genau an.
(EIN FÜHRENDER AKTEUR - IN WAHRSTEN SINNE
DES WORTES)
Als die Sowjetunion Anfang der 1990er Jahre
zusammenbrach, war die neue unabhängige Ukraine
einer der wirtschaftlich wohlhabendsten postkommunistischen
Staaten.
Also, ich meien "wohlhabend" im Sinne des
sowjetischen Kontextes.
Denn die Wahrheit ist, dass alles, was aus
der ehemaligen Sowjetunion hervorging, ein
heilloses Chaos war.
Dennoch war das preisbereinigte Pro-Kopf-BIP
der Ukraine etwa 20% höher als das Polens.
Und wenn diese Differenz bis heute erhalten
geblieben wäre und die Ukraine es geschafft
hätte, einen ebenso effektiven politischen
und wirtschaftlichen Übergang wie Polen oder
Tschechien zu vollziehen, entspräche die
ukrainische Wirtschaft heute fast zwei Dritteln
der russischen.
Aber wie ihr alle wisst, verlief die Geschichte
natürlich ganz anders.
Die drei Jahrzehnte der ukrainischen Unabhängigkeit
waren geprägt von wirtschaftlicher Stagnation,
innerer Spaltung und einem institutionellen
Verfall, der die Ukraine zum ärmsten Land
in ganz Europa machte.
Die Krise war so groß, dass die ukrainische
Wirtschaft bis 2005 nicht über das Niveau
von 1989 hinauskam.
Diese Misere war eine der Voraussetzungen
für die russische Invasion der Krim, die
Abstaltung des Donbas und später für die
Invasion des ganzen Landes.
In den letzten 10 Jahren haben sich die Dinge
in der Ukraine jedoch stark verändert und
in Kiew konnte einen wichtigen und mächtigen
Partner für die Umsetzung dieses ganzen Reformprozesses
finden.
Von wem hier die Rede ist?
Natürlich von Polen.
Im letzten Jahrzehnt war Polen vielleicht
das Land, das die politische, wirtschaftliche
und sogar kulturelle Entwicklung der Ukraine
am meisten beeinflusst hat.
Es war sein stärkster Unterstützer innerhalb
der Europäischen Union und der NATO, es nahm
vor der Invasion mehr als 1,5 Millionen ukrainische
Migranten auf und gab diesem Land ein Modell,
um den Sprung auf den Zug der gesellschaftlichen
und wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung zu schaffen.
Wir sprechen hier über zwei Länder mit sehr
engen Beziehungen zueinander.
Tatsächlich waren sie jahrhundertelang Teil
der Polnisch-Litauischen Gemeinschaft und
in jüngerer Zeit lehnten sie gemeinsam die
sowjetische Besatzung ab.
("Es kann weder ein freies Polen ohne eine
freie Ukraine noch eine freie Ukraine ohne
ein freies Polen geben."
- Polnische Volksweisheit)
Nun, nach dem russischen Überfall auf die
Ukraine ist Polen zu einem der Hauptakteure
in den politischen Nachrichten geworden und
auch das Land, das die europäischen Kriegsvorbereitungen
anführt.
(DIE NEUE MACHT POLONIAS)
Der Einmarsch Russlands in die Ukraine hat
Polen zu einem der Hauptakteure in der Krise
gemacht.
Das Land, das zusammen mit den Vereinigten
Staaten und Großbritannien die Ukraine am
stärksten unterstützt, Waffen liefert und
Hunderttausende, Millionen von Flüchtlingen
aufnimmt.
Allein in den ersten drei Wochen nach der
russischen Invasion nahm Polen mehr als zwei
Millionen Flüchtlinge auf.
Damit Ihr EUch eine Vorstellung davon machen
könnt: Praktisch über Nacht landete das
Land auf der Weltrangliste der Länder mit
den meisten aufgenommenen Flüchtlingen auf
Platz vier, hinter der Türkei, Kolumbien
und den USA.
Seit Beginn des Krieges haben die polnische
Regierung und die ganze polnische Zivilgesellschaft
ein beispielloses System aus Unterkünften,
Transportmitteln, Lebensmitteln, psychologischer
Unterstützung und Hilfe aller Art aufgebaut.
Die polnische Regierung zahlt sogar kleine
monatliche Zuwendungen an Familien, die aus
der Ukraine gekommen sind, um ihnen das Leben
zu erleichtern.
Flüchtlinge dürfen im Land nach Arbeit suchen
und sie wurden auch ins Gesundheits- und Bildungssystem
aufgenommen.
Zehntausende ukrainischer Kinder gehen bereits
auf polnische Schulen.
Wir sprechen hier von einer gigantischen Anstrengung
und gleichzeitig eine gigantischen Chance
für die polnische Wirtschaft, denn die Ukrainer
sind in der Regel gut ausgebildet und fleißig,
zählen allgemein zu den eher emanzipationsaffinen
Migrantengruppen.
Und das ist noch nicht alles.
Polen ist auch zum Einfallstor für westliche
Waffen und Lieferungen in die Ukraine und
zu einem der wichtigsten politischen Akteure
der Gegenwart geworden.
(Der Ukraine-Krieg macht Polen zu Amerikas
"unverzichtbarem" Verbündeten.
Politico)
Mit anderen Worten: Polen ist plötzlich zu
einem der größten Widersacher von Putin-Russland
geworden.
Und es ist auch ein Beispiel für den militärischen
Wettlauf nach vorn.
Denn Polen ist dabei, seine Streitkräfte
von etwa 110.000 Soldaten auf rund 250.000
zu verdoppeln und will gleichzeitig eine der
modernsten Armeen Europas werden.
("Es ist ein außergewöhnlicher und historischer
Moment.
Die Einführung Polens in eine völlig neue
Welt von Spitzentechnologie, moderner Waffen
und Verteidigungsmaßnahmen".
- Andrzej Duda, Präsident Polens)
Denn wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass Polen
eine direkte Grenze zu Russland hat - nämlich
bei Kaliningrad.
Und natürlich auch zu Putins engstem militärischen
Verbündeten: Weißrussland.
Von diesem wurde es bereits vor dem Krieg
durch einen organisierten und instrumentalisierten
Migrantenansturm angegriffen - wir haben darüber
ein Video gedreht, das ich Euch verlinken
werde.
Schließlich ist Polen immer wieder eines
der beliebtesten Ziele direkter Gewalt- und
Kriegsandrohungen aus dem Kreml.
Erst jüngst regte der Duma-Abgeordnete Oleg
Morozov, der für Putins Partei „Einiges
Russland“ im Parlament sitzt in seiner Telegram-Gruppe
an, Polen solle nach der „Entnazifizierung“
der Ukraine gleich als nächstes Land auf
Russlands „Spezialoperationsliste“ gesetzt
werden.
Es ist daher überhaupt nicht verwunderlich,
dass Polen eines der wenigen europäischen
Länder ist, dessen Militärhaushalt die von
der NATO als Mindestziel gesetzten 2% des
BIP übersteigt und zwar schon lange, bevor
dies cool war.
2021 kündigte der stellvertretende polnische
Ministerpräsident Jarosław Kaczyński, der
heimliche Herrscher Polens, im Oktober sogar
an, das Land wolle seine Militärausgaben
auf mindestens 3 % des BIP erhöhen.
So will die polnische Regierung nicht nur
die Größe ihrer Streitkräfte mehr als verdoppeln,
sondern auch ihre territorialen Verteidigungskräfte
ausbauen - eine Unterstützungsarmee aus freiwilligen
Soldaten - und vor allem ihr Waffenarsenal
modernisieren, indem sie Kampfsysteme aus
der Sowjetzeit durch moderne, NATO-kompatible
Ausrüstung ersetzt.
Große Teile dieser nach wie vor gut gewarteten
und einsatzbereiten Altbestände landen nun
in der Ukraine.
Aber was meint Ihr: gibt es einen besseren
Zeitpunkt, um aufzuräumen?
Die polnische Armee verfügte zum Beispiel
noch über etwa 500 T-72-Panzer, als die russische
Offensive begann.
Und in der polnischen Luftwaffe gibt es immer
noch einige Mig-29 und Su-22.
Alles deutet jedoch darauf hin, dass sich
diese Situation sehr bald ändern wird.
Und das nicht nur wegen der Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine.
Im Juli 2021 kündigte die polnische Regierung
zum Beispiel den Kauf von 250 US-amerikanischen
Abrams-Panzern an, um die 250 Leopard 2 zu
ergänzen, die sie derzeit in ihrem Bestand
hat.
Ein weiteres Beispiel ist die alternde Luftwaffe
des Landes.
In den letzten zehn Jahren ist die Zahl der
einsatzfähigen Kampfjets in Polen von 128
auf 98 gesunken.
Um hier Abhilfe zu schaffen, kündigte die
Regierung im Jahr 2020 einen 4,6-Milliarden-Dollar-Deal
an, der für 32 F-35 umfasst, die 2024 geliefert
werden sollen und im selben Jahr erwarb sie
auch ein Flugabwehrsystem vom Typ Patriot
für 4,8 Milliarden Dollar.
Im Mai 2021 kameb 24 türkische Bayraktar
TB2-Drohnen hinzu, eine der derzeitige Schlüsselwaffen
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte und Albträume
russicher Panzerbesatzungen.
Alles in allem ist das aber nur ein Tropfen
auf den heißen Stein.
Um seine Streitkräfte zu modernisieren, wird
Polen in den nächsten Jahren große haushaltstechnische
Anstrengungen unternehmen müssen, zu welchen
die Regierung jedoch mehr als bereit zu sein
scheint.
Und das sagen nicht nur wir, sondern auch
der stellvertretende Ministerpräsident und
Vorsitzende der Regierungspartei, Jarosław
Kaczyński, selbst.
("Es ist besser, Sicherheit zu haben und sich
dafür ein bisschen mehr zu verschulden."
- Jaroslaw Kaczyński, stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
Polens)
Eines ist also klar: Polen gibt in Europa
Verteidigungs- und Sicherheitspolitisch bereits
heute die Marschrichtung vor und der große
Rest folgt so schnell er kann.
Der einstige Motor der EU, die "Achse" Berlin-Paris,
ist nur noch mit deutlich hörbarem Getriebeschaden
unterwegs, den sie sich selbst durch die unsachgemäßte
Nutzung des Rückwärtsgangs eingebrockt hat.
Aufgepasst!
(DER FIGHT CLUB)
Mit Ausnahme Ungarns - über das wir bald
ein eigens Video drehen werden - ist man in
ganz Mittel- und Mittelosteuropa überdeutlich:
Niemand traut mehr Moskau auch nur einen Fingerbreit
über den Weg.
Mehr noch: Aufgrund der offen zur Schau gestellten
opportunistischen Unzuverlässigkeit der beiden
Mäche Deutschland und Frankreich wird selbst
die Zugehörigkeit zur NATO wird nicht als
ausreichender Schutz angesehen.
Auf die eine oder andere Weise fangen also
fast alle Länder in dieser Region an, sich
aufzuraffen, um in Polens Fußstapfen zu treten.
Ein gutes Beispiel ist Tschechien, ein Land,
für das Verteidigungsausgaben in den letzten
Jahren nicht gerade eine Priorität waren,
da es sich im Schutz seines großen Nachbarn
Deutschland wähnte.
Im Jahr 2022 wurden beispielsweise nur schlappe
1,35 % des BIP für die Verteidigung veranschlagt
und diese waren schon ein deutlicher Sprung
gegenüber den 0,95 %, die sie 2015 ausgegeben
haben.
Aber all das klingt heute wie ein Märchen
aus einer anderen Zeit.
Die tschechische Regierung hat angekündigt,
dass sie ihr Militärbudget bis 2025 um 60
% erhöhen will.
Auch Bulgarien, Rumänien und die baltischen
Republiken kündigen erhebliche Erhöhungen
ihrer Militärbudgets an.
(Rumänien will Verteidigungsausgaben auf
2,5% des BIP erhöhen - Euractiv)
Auch Estland, Lettland und Litauen werden
ihre Militärausgaben um deutlich mehr als
2% erhöhen.
(Litauen will über 1 Mrd. € für Waffen
aus den USA und Deutschland ausgeben - LRT)
Natürlich geht es bei der Kriegsvorbereitung
nicht nur um Militärausgaben oder politische
Beziehungen.
Es gibt noch viele weitere Variablen, die
wir berücksichtigen müssen.
Eine davon, eine sehr wichtige, ist die Infrastruktur.
Es mag Euch überraschen, aber diese kann
im Ernstfall ein kriegsentscheidender Schwachpunkt
sein.
Um einen Krieg zu gewinnen oder eine wirksame
Abschreckungsstrategie zu verfolgen, brauchst
du nicht nur eine Armee, du musst sie auch
bewegen und versorgen können.
Genau aus diesem Grund wurde 2021 die "Connecting
Europe Facility" vereinbart, ein Finanzierungsinstrument
der Europäischen Union, das 1,7 Milliarden
Dollar zur Verbesserung der militärischen
Mobilität bereitstellt.
Wir sprechen jedoch über ein sehr knappes
Budget zu einer Zeit, in der der Krieg deutlich
gemacht hat, dass diese Art von Präventivmaßnahmen
notwendig ist.
Mit der russischen Invasion der Ukraine wurde
diese Thema natürlich zu einer absoluten
Priorität: Straßen- und Eisenbahninfrastruktur,
Brücken, Häfen und Flughäfen werden nun
fit für den Verteidigungsfall gemacht, so
ausgebaut und mit allem ausgestattet, damit,
falls nötig, eine große Zahl von Truppen
schnell an die Front verlegt werden kann.
Es handelt sich um einen der wichtigsten Faktoren
im Rahmen der Kaltstartfähigkeit unserer
Streitkräfte und betrifft besonders dringend
das östliche Mitteleuropa, wo viele wichtige
Infrastrukturelemente wie Brücken dem Gewicht
amerikanischer, britischer oder deutscher
Panzer nicht standhalten können.
("In Europa hat man die Ansicht vertreten,
dass wir keine Ausgaben für die Verteidigung
brauchen.
Seit dem 24. Februar - als Russland die Ukraine
angegriffen hat - hat sich diese Ansicht komplett
geändert."
- Georg Riekeles, Analyst am Zentrum für
Europäische Politik)
Eines der Projekte, das am meisten beschleunigt
werden könnte, ist zum Beispiel Rail Baltica,
eine 5,8 Milliarden Euro teure normalspurige
Eisenbahnverbindung, die Estland, Lettland
und Litauen mit Polen verbinden soll.
Es handelt sich um absolut unverzichtbare
Infrastruktur, mit welche sichergestellt wird,
dass große Truppenbewegungen schnell durchgeführt
werden können.
Im Rahmen des finnischen Aufnahmeantrags für
die NATO gibt es sogar Überlegungen, diese
Strecke von Estland nach Finnland durch einen
Tunnel unter dem Meer zu verlängern.
Und das ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs.
Durch die rasche NATO-Erweiterung, die Putin
ausgelöst hat können wir erwarten, dass
noch viele weitere militärische Infrastrukturprojekte
ordentlich an Fahrt aufnehmen werden.
Wie ihr seht stellt Infrastruktur eine wichtige
Möglichkeit ist, sich auf einen Krieg vorzubereiten
und Europas Abschreckungsstrategie zu verbessern.
Europa wird zu einer Festung ausgebaut und
der Geist der Wehrhaftigkeit und Resilienz
dürfte aus dem Militärischen bald auch in
alle anderen gesellschaftlichen Bereiche durchsickern.
Polen gibt auch hierbei wieder den Ton an,
bringt es doch schließlich - wie andere Länder
in der Region - eine Menge historisches Rüstzeug
mit, durch welches es für diese Führungsrolle
geradezu prädestiniert ist.
Die Geschichte lehrt uns immer wieder, dass
ein militärischer Sieg nicht immer auch einen
geopolitischen Sieg bedeuten muss.
Manchmal führt Krieg einfach immer nur in
die Niederlage, egal was auf dem Schlachtfeld
passiert.
Die Erfahrungen der USA in Afghanistan und
im Irak machen dies ebenso deutlich wie Moskaus
eigene Erfahrungen mit dem Einmarsch in Ungarn
1956, dem Überfall der Tschechoslowakei 1968
oder der Verhängung des Kriegsrechts in Polen
1981.
In all diesen Fällen war der Triumph auf
den Schlachtfeldern nicht gleichbedeutend
mit einem Sieg.
Im Gegenteil: bei den militärischen Triumphen
handelte es sich um Pyrrhussiege, durch welche
es die Herzen der Menschen noch weiter verlor.
Die Sowjetunion hatte den Kalten Krieg eigentlich
damals bereits verloren, da sie nicht einmal
in der Lage war, ihre Verbündeten aus dem
Warschauer Pakt zu vereinen und für sich
zu gewinnen.
Tatsächlich haben sich die Russen selbst
durch ihre militärischen Intervention in
all diesen Fällen bei den tschechischen,
polnischen und auch vielen ungarische Bürgern
immer weiter verhasst gemacht.
Sie hatten nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg, den
sie an der Seite Nazi-Deutschlands, zunächst
die großartige Chance, ihren fatalen Fehler
zu korrigieren und als wahre Befreier zu gelten.
Doch diese erstickten sie durch ihre Tyrannei
und Herrschsucht.
Daher wird unabhängig davon, was auf den
Schlachtfeldern der Ukraine passiert, der
dortige Krieg wieder genau das Gegenteil dessen
bewirken, was Moskau beabsichtigt:
Die Distanz, das Misstrauen und die Feindseligkeit
der Ukrainer gegenüber Russland wurden nun
auf Generationen hinweg in die sowieso schon
vom Holodomor traumatisierte Volksseele eingebrannt
und das gleiche gilt auch für die übrigen
Völker in der Region.
Russland ist für so gut wie all seine Nachbarn
zu einem Schimpfwort geworden, einem Symbol
für Terror, Unmenschlichkeit und unverbesserliche
gesellschaftliche Rückständigkeit.
Es hat sich endgültig aus dem Kulturkreis
des europäischen Humanismus verabschiedet.
Die NATO hingegen wird stärker, geschlossener,
besser vorbereitet und mit neuen Mitgliedern
aus all dieser Not hervorgehen - über all
das werden wir bald hier auf VisualPolitik
sprechen.
Wenn Putin wollte, dass die NATO weniger gegen
Russland geeint ist, hat er das genau Gegenteil
erreicht.
Russland wird nun eine Grenze mit viel stärker
bewaffneten und befestigten Nachbarn haben.
Jahrelang hat Russland versucht, seine ehemaligen
Vsalklenstaaten aus dem Warschauer Paktes
einzuschüchtern, doch nun hat es sie endgültig
dazu ermutigt, Russland selbstständig gegenüber
zu treten und in die Augen zu schauen und
Polen wird durch diese nicht mehr zu stoppende
Dynamik zu einer Kontinentalmacht aufsteigen.
Es hat das Zeug dazu, Russland sowohl militärisch
als auch wirtschaftlich ganz alleine zu übertrumpfen
- und es geht dieses Ziel nun konsequent an,
sozusagen auch als späte Genugtuung für
den gemeinsam mit Hitler-Deutschland durch
die Sowjets begannenen Überfall auf das Land
und zahlreiche Kriegsverbrechen, wie das Massaker
von Katyn.
Wenn wir einen Preis für die absurdeste,
hirnrissigste und kontra-produktivste politische
Idee des letzten Jahrzehnts vergeben sollten,
wäre es schwer, einen besseren Kandidaten
als Putin mit seiner abscheulichen Invasion
der Ukraine zu finden.
Er hat das Antlitz Europas für immer verändert
und zwar in jenes, das ihm von allem Möglichkeiten
am allerwenigsten gefällt.
Das Machtgleichgewicht hat sich so gewissermaßen
nach Osten verschoben, aber ganz, ganz anders
als es sich Putin und seine fünfte Kolonne
in der EU ausgerechnet haben.
Aber über diese neue Zukunftsregion, die
neue Mitte Europas, werden noch so manches
Video drehen.
Vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo - und noch
viel wichtiger: das Glöckchen, um keines
dieser Videos zu verpassen.
Die Bedeutung dieser wird nicht nur aufgrund
ihrer eigenen Entschlossenheit und Energie
enorm steigen, sondern auch, weil nach der
Befreiung und Stabilisierung der Ukraine das
gebeutelte Land und seine Nachbarn einen unvergleichlichen
Aufhol- und Erneuerungsprozess - einen gigantischen
Boom – erleben dürften.
Unsere Prognose aus dem vorletzten Video,
gemäß der Polen gar die Wirtschaftaftskraft
Russlands, das vier mal mehr Einwohner hat,
überholen könnte, ist angesichts dieses
Szenarios also gar nicht mal unrealistisch.
Überlegt mal: War die russische Volkswirtschaft
im Jahr 2014 noch vier mal so groß wie die
Polens, so erreichte die polnische Wirtschaftsleistung
7 Jahre später bereits 40% der Russlands
und dürfte nun nach dem Kriegseinbruch die
50%-Marke gerissen haben.
Und an dieser Stelle muss ich noch unbedingt
mit einem weit verbreiteten Vorurteil aufräumen,
welches aufgrund dieser Zahlen in den Kommentaren
zu besagtem Videoaufkam: nein, dies liegt
nicht allein an den EU-Subvetionen, die nach
Polen geflossen sind.
Die europäische Integration hat Polen, Tschechien,
der Slowakei, Ungarn und anderen Staaten zwar
eine produktivere Wirtschaft und vile Jobs
gebracht, das Problem ist jedoch: die Gewinne
ihrer Wirtschaft fließen zu einem großen
Teil in den Westen ab.
In der Summe übersteigen diese Dividendenabflüsse
nach Westeuropa – zumeist nach Deutschland
– die staatlichen Transfers aus dem EU-Haushalt
sogar bei weitem und das schon seit Jahren.
Zwischen 2010 und 2016 hat Polen 4,7 Prozent
seiner Wirtschaftsleistung als Kapitaleinkommen
gen Westen geschickt - und zugleich nur 2,7
Prozent netto aus dem EU-Haushalt erhalten.
Noch ungünstiger fällt die Bilanz für Ungarn
und Tscheschien aus.
Die Ungarn überweise ganze 7,2 Prozent ihre
Bruttoinlandsprodukts gen Westen und bekommen
nur 4 Prozent zurück und die Tschechen…
jetzt haltet Euch fest...
die Tschechen drücken sage und schreibe 7,6
Prozent ab und bekommen dafür nur magere
1,9 Prozent.
Die wahren Nettozahler der EU sind also ganz
klar diese Staaten Mittel- und Mittelosteuropas.
Und während die Ungleichheit innerhalb dieser
Länder gering bleibt, entsteht ein kolonialähnliches
Verhältnis zur ausländischen Oberschicht.
Der polnische und tschechische Facharbeiter
malocht also als Leistungsträger für ein
Drittel oder die Hälfte des Gehalts damit
die deutschen, französischen und niederländischen
Aktionäre Megaprofite abräumen dürfen.
Und wie gesagt: wie reden hier nicht von Peanuts
sondern Milliardenbeträge, die durchaus einen
beträchtlichen Teil dieser Volkswirtschaften
ausmachen.
Aber jetzt ist erstmal Eure Meinung gefragt:
Was haltet Ihr von den Plänen und Aufstiegschancen
der mittel- und osteuropäischen Länder?
Glaubt Ihr, dass Polen sich irgendwann zu
einer vollwertigen führenden europäischen
Macht entwickeln wird?
Welche weiteren Erfolgsfaktoren könnt Ihr
identifizieren und über welche sollten wir
in näher analysieren?
Sollte der Rest Europas diesem Beispiel folgen?
Wie immer sind wir schon auf Eure Beiträge
im Kommentarbereich gespannt!
Ich hoffe, dass Euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und Ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habt.
Falls ja, gebt uns bitte ein Like, teilt es
mit Euren Freunden und vergesst nicht das
Abo mit Glöckchen, um keines unserer Videos
mehr zu verpassen.
Natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von Euch, mit der Ihr uns helft,
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen.
Den PayPal-Link dazu findet Ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video.
Macht’s gut und bis bald!